rated M for Mature hi everyone I'm
Daniel Nixon the community lead on
Friday the 13th the game today we're
going to show you a walkthrough of
broken down the tutorial level for our
upcoming single-player challenges please
keep in mind that these are a work in
progress and that the gameplay shown is
one of many ways to complete this
challenge
we hope you enjoy fix that [ __ ] you
might be faster if you helped man man
just hurry up I want to miss the hot
chicks at the party
so young so pretty
kill them all Jason sure your yeah I was
your girl banger yet Bugsy anyone ever
tell you to shut the [ __ ] up
need to go drain ELISA
don't stop Jason they deserve to die
make them suffer like we did
[Music]
this small tutorial challenge is just a
taste of what's to come with numerous
objectives per challenge bigger levels
and multiple targets we think the Jason
will have his hands full stay tuned to
our forums and Twitter for more updates
like these and thank you for watching